hi i'm nicole stott nicole stott is a
retired astronaut and here's me in space
today I'm going to look at how
astronauts are portrayed in Hollywood
blackout period in Apollo 13 we have
lost the radio contact Roger that expect
to regain signal in three minutes this
blackout period does happen it's not
unique to Apollo 13
no reiteration ship has never taken
longer than three minutes to emerge from
blackout still today when we have Soyuz
landings the Soyuz capsule coming back
in it's a predicted time it's it's
understood where it should happen okay
like that's three minutes we are
standing by for acquisition they'll let
you know hey we will lose comm with the
crew for 30 seconds or a minute or
whatever it might be this is Houston do
you read and then you'll always get the
ground calling a little bit early ahead
to you know see if they've regained
communications or not
posses
for some reason even when you know
that's gonna happen there's this like
you know you're kind of at the edge of
your seat okay we're gonna hear back
from we're gonna hear back from them but
it's just the physics of coming back
into the atmosphere you've got this like
really hot plasma coming around the ship
that ionizes the atmosphere and causes
this disruption of you know the ability
to communicate
[Music]
and then it stops and you can talk again
wormhole travel contact
when I look at this scene I'm thinking
yeah it's gonna be you know it's gonna
be in the future a little bit but I
think you would still have a spacesuit
and a helmet on and maybe not just be in
this little sea it seems like there's
some more substance to what she's
sitting in there when we launch to space
and when we land we where they're
actually called ascent entry spacesuits
if you watched a space shuttle launch or
landing you'd always see the crew in
these orange suits the purpose of the
suit was to help you survive if all the
air in your spaceship went away or if
you got into kind of a critical
emergency situation and so you'd have
the suit on it could pressurize up to
keep your you know your blood flowing
right
you had the helmet on so that you could
breathe air and I think that's going to
go on for a long time the new spaceships
we're building we're incorporating
spacesuits into the launch and landing
of those because those are two of the
most critical stages of the flight
I'm the control-room scene and the way
they're communicating with her and
preparation for launch and kind of the
stages that they go through all sounds
you know very familiar kind of what you
would expect through a launch sequence
when you can't hear ground control the
crew will still continue to speak in
hopes that maybe you're just you know
not hearing their response to you but
they can hear you so a lot of times
we'll use the words like in the blind
you know I'm just gonna keep talking to
you and hope that you hear me
and so that you can stay you know up to
speed as much about what's going on with
me and then hopefully at some point I'll
hear you again ai on spaceships and 2001
Space Odyssey open the pod bay doors
hell I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't
do that right now I think the the
current status of artificial
intelligence or AI on our space missions
is that we're not really saying we have
AI in place I think that will come
there's some things that we're testing
what we do have is automated control of
things open the pod bay doors and that's
a great thing because then the crew
isn't having to interact all the time to
maintain the systems or ensure that
everything is good
that can happen automatically even when
we're flying the spacecraft there's
automation associated with that a lot of
it but in every case I believe we're
still in the situation where we can
manually take over if we need to either
as the crew members on board or from the
ground through the control systems that
they have I think you know what the
problem is just as well as I do our hope
is that the AI whichever ones we do
employ at some point are not set up that
they could take control this mission is
too important for me to allow you to
jeopardize it asteroid belt and
get it buddy hang on just a little
yeah this is one of those scenes that I
think shows there's there is a lot
that's far fetched in Armageddon
land might not be the right word to use
with Astrid I think it's more like
you're docking with it you're
intercepting it and then keeping pace
and attaching somehow just because of
the you know the physics of an asteroid
and the way it moves through space and
we're looking at how you do that right
now we have missions that have gone to
asteroids and you know small spacecraft
that have gone there and done that and
taking pictures and landed on it I
suppose there's a lot of work going on
right now into how we track asteroids
how we identify them and then maybe even
more importantly once we know they're
there what do we do about them if
they're like in the scenario in this
film if they're actually coming towards
Earth and could be a real threat to us
and they're looking at missions that
could you know resolve that for us I
think one thing is a crew member that
bothers me when I watch scenes like this
is this is absolutely a time when you
would have your helmet on
some of the the terminology that's used
like Mayday Mayday you know I get what
they're what they're doing it's like hey
they're gonna go down but Mayday Mayday
implies that somebody could get there to
rescue you and that is not likely at all
in this kind of scenario I mean I was
excited by watching this movie though
too so on the two missions that I flew
in space and the ones that we have done
even going to the moon we're not flying
through asteroid belts we have not as
human beings done that yet when I think
about an asteroid or a meteor perhaps is
more appropriate for the kind of mission
I've had is I'm thinking about these
single small pieces of debris that might
have the potential of hitting my
spacecraft versus ever considering the
idea that I'm gonna have to fly through
this massive you know belt of huge and
small pieces of debris g-force training
in space Cowboys
this thing moving
[Music]
sure we'll take the wrinkles out so we
have the opportunity as shuttle crew
members to go experience the the
centrifuge so this machine that kind of
spins you around and simulates not just
the g-forces that you'll feel you
experience them like you would as you
were launching so it takes you through
the same trajectory that you would
experience launching on the Space
Shuttle and they mentioned it in the
film it's it's three G's is what it's
limited to and you're on your back and
it's coming through your chest we're so
pleased I love the interaction between
these guys that have been friends and
like frenemies even you know throughout
the years first one to pass out by
severe denies they go right back to kind
of this competitive yet light like
friendly competition in here
even in the end when they're like waking
back up and it's not oh my gosh what
happened it's hey who passed out first
[Music]
was just something very human and nice
about that to me I'm getting too old for
this video messages in interstellar you
once told me that when you came back we
might be the same age and today I'm the
age you were when you left from the
station we're able to talk on the
basically on a phone every every day so
I would have a pretty normal
conversation with my son after school
every day and once a week we would do a
video conference and now it's amazing
the family members can take an iPad with
them and they can go to their kids game
and show you know the crew member on
board hey you know there's Joey kick in
the you know the home run or whatever it
is and it's really interesting to see
just in that short period of time the
way we've improved the communications
even in a delayed timeframe to be able
to have that connection you know home to
our family or our friends or even just
to see you know views of the planet will
be really really important orbital
mechanics and the Martian intercept
velocity will be 11 meters per second I
can make that work
distance at intercept will be will be 68
kilometers apart they mentioned
something about not having a you know
enough velocity
you know this difference in velocity and
that's really important because you have
to kind of match up the velocities in
order to be able to intercept something
in space I could use the escaping air as
a semester so Watney is saying hey why
don't I make that up by giving myself a
little bit more thrust by making my suit
into essentially a rocket engine I get
to fly around like Iron Man that's why
he jokes around about it being like Iron
Man too cuz you use his glove and then
fly little thrusters out of his hands
and I like that they did this from a
control standpoint might be a lot more
difficult than what they show all they
you know eventually show them kind of
flopping around while he does it but
it's looking for a solution it's like
taking advantage of what the resources
you have to try to overcome the problem
that you're dealing with come on guys
keep it together work the problem as
long I think as that air is flowing by
his hand it's technically not exposed to
the vacuum of space just like the rest
of his body isn't
he's still protected as long as there's
that airflow oxygen in the spacesuit Red
Planet oxygen supply completed I think
the the normal supply and a suit that we
go out on a spacewalk with has between
six and eight hours worth of oxygen and
how long that lasts will depend on how
fast you're breathing how hard you're
working but but usually six to eight
hours and then that's the normal like
primary tanks in case you did get a leak
or something went wrong we have some
secondary tanks that are really intended
for you to use them to get back into the
station or to get to a safe place where
you could either resupply or just you
know get back in those I think lasts for
like half an hour replace your o2
canister immediately the ground can
monitor the systems in our suit
they've got telemetry to be able to tell
us how much oxygen we have left we've
got little sensors on the suit itself
and a little display panel right here
that you can look down at that if you
push the buttons right it could tell you
here's how much oxygen you know you have
remaining the pressure and the estimated
time and then when it gets to a certain
level an audible alarm will go off in
your helmet let you know hey you're at
this point and then you would talk to
the ground or your crewmates inside to
decide what what you do about it
on Mars we're not going to be able to
just go out without a suit on
yeah the atmosphere is not one that we
can just breathe without any kind of
protection or or air supply that's why
in this movie it's kind of surprising
that they you know at the the next stage
where they open up their helmet and are
breathing normally they that they didn't
know that I think they would have known
that that was breathable air yeah we go
to Mars we're gonna have to be in
spacesuits all the time outside wooden
rocket wallace and gromit
[Music]
you could definitely build a wooden
rocket I don't think there's anything
stopping us from doing that but just
because of really because of how much
energy you have to put behind it the
spaceship would be at risk of catching
fire anytime you ignited a thruster
I think structurally the wood just
wouldn't hold together as you're going
through all these different loads and
accelerations that you would see go into
space wallace and gromit they build you
know kind of that iconic looking rocket
shape and we actually when we first
started building rockets we built them
with that shape if you look at the new
spaceship that Elon Musk is proposing
for going to Mars it has that very
iconic smooth and then the you know the
fins at the end it's an efficient way to
move through the atmosphere in space
just the shape of that rocket but we've
found over time that there's other ways
to get that same kind of efficiency so
you don't have to build it that way
hidden figures launch
yeah max-q is something that all of our
spacecraft go through it's where you
reach this like maximum pressure on the
outside of the spacecraft if you stay at
that pressure for you know a period of
time it has the potential to tear the
spaceship apart so on the space Space
Shuttle you know here's something okay
max Q and then we would throttle back to
relieve the load on the spaceship lunar
rover and moon
[Music]
in this scene I look at the rover and it
looks totally believable you know if you
if you see the Rovers that NASA is
developing right now for you know our
return to the moon and potentially even
for use on Mars they have kind of this
bigger bulkier look than the little
almost go-cart looking you know vehicles
we had in the Apollo missions and
they're meant to be vehicles that you
can actually you could actually travel
in and live in for some period of time
without having to have your helmet on
and using your spacesuit and that you
could go out from them and do excursions
you know on the surface launch space
cowboys
[Music]
let's have a comm check be okay ms one
ms - I think the whole scene here where
they're walking down the you know the
walkway the crew access arm is what we
called it was kind of this walkway that
got you into the hatch and onto the
shuttle all looked really good to me
the scenes in Mission Control and launch
control center looked really good the
way they were speaking through the
countdown was great this whole scene for
launch is is really pretty accurate in
the movie it bothered me a little bit
that on re-entry they had the pilot
flying versus the commander flying in
the left seat in reality on landing it
would be the commander in the left seat
that would be doing all of the flying
for the landing and not the pilot in the
right seat a robot in space Wally
[Music]
Wally's here like clinging on to the
side of the spaceship as it launches I
think the point is that that Wally's a
machine too so if this metal machine
even though we want to love it is you
know can clasp on to this side of the
vehicle and is made of materials that
will tolerate that environment then I
think that's probably not an
unbelievable thing I don't know if
they'd ever be the satellites that you
see the the spaceship going through will
ever be bunched up like that but there's
a lot of them circling our earth right
now you know there's some in low-earth
orbit and there's you know what is it
like the geosynchronous this is like you
know 24,000 miles above the planet and
you know when we talk about going
further and further off the earth to get
to places we certainly have to consider
that right now we do that by knowing
exactly you know where they are in space
and then our trajectory that takes us
out further somehow misses them I don't
know it's a mystery to me
[Music]
landing a ship prometheus for us to
notice the captain brace for entry
gage laying a sequence twister manual
commence landing
from the space station when we undocked
with the space shuttle and then we're
gonna re-enter and land from the time we
fired those retro thrusters you know are
the thrusters that would allow us to
slow down and enter back into the
atmosphere it was an hour from firing
them to touching down on the runway but
I like this scene great I think they go
through some of the same sequences we
would if we were landing everybody gets
in their seats you know it's a little
bit more in advance than what they're
showing here but this is a futuristic
movie - it seems to me they're doing
these kinds of landings and reentry's
pretty regularly we're gonna love that
they use terms that we that we do like
okay firing the RCS you know which is
the reaction control system which is the
thrusters that would allow you to either
slow down or speed up or move forward
backwards you know to fly the spacecraft
and then they physically show the you
know the thruster is moving down into a
position that would fire against the
earth to you know to slow them down and
then let them settle onto that planet
it's very future it's very sci-fi but
they're incorporating some things that
we use all the time
I really in this film like the line
right there God does not build in
straight lines
God doesn't build in straight lines
because that's something as a crew you
would notice nature is much more random
and yeah that was really interesting to
me that they would incorporate something
like that yeah wouldn't be any good if I
could do that
Gold spacesuits in sunshine
our spacesuits are not made out of you
know all gold material but we do use the
gold visors when we're going to be in
the Sun to protect our eyes from that
solar radiation so when you're in space
and in you know in microgravity floating
where nothing really weighs anything it
doesn't matter how much the spacesuit
weighs you're still gonna be able to
move around in it easily so we're not so
worried about that we're more worried
about the materials and how it's going
to protect you in that environment I
don't know that we're ever gonna send
people to the Sun but if if we did they
might need gold spacesuits Muppets pigs
in space cleaning the space station
happens all the time I think we are just
kind of perpetually doing it you really
get into the mode of just clean up after
yourself as you go and then on the
weekends we would have like a whole list
of housekeeping tasks that we do you
know the vacuum cleaner was a lot of fun
kind of fly around on the vacuum cleaner
don't worry my little seminar you don't
have to take out the trash because I
just send it out the hatch yesterday the
way we deal with trash on the space
station is that we have these these
cargo vehicles that have come up loaded
with new supplies for us and we when we
unload those we put all of our trash
that we've collected into them most of
those ships burn up in the atmosphere
what I mean it's really a very clean
effective way to get rid of your trash
we have to do this job anyway conclusion
I hope you've enjoyed this kind of
comparison between what goes on in the
movies and what happens in real life as
much as I have I am so thankful for the
science fiction that we are presented
with I think it gives us an opportunity
to think about what our future could be
like already we've seen so much sci-fi
that's turned into SCI fact that I am
really hopeful for what we'll see in the
few
and I hope that we can continue to
compare over time what we're doing in
real life and how we're imagining it in
the sci-fi movies
[Applause]